okay and welcome to the first video of
them and repertoire series for 1d form
this video will focus on them d4 d5
which basically means the Queen's Gambit
or other try some adjust the tattoo to
tame to really play for an advantage and
of course they're playable but
especially if you want to play really in
an aggressive way you have no choice but
to play the Queens gambit with your form
I am actually um suggest to really play
it the second move and not and go from
Knight f3 first and then C form it is
possible of course but it it severely
limits the options that that white will
have in the future especially if black
goes 46 on this point um you already
have committed the knight on f3 and the
sermon it's not bad of course but leads
to entirely different lines than the
ones when I once I should suggest for
the repertoire so we go on C form and of
course now black has three main moves
and a couple of um less common responses
many moves are of course some one is the
second eighty-six the classical Queen's
Gambit on c6 Slav and DC for the Queens
gambit accepted off the railroad lines
the only ones only one ones really worth
studying
somewhat um um yeah the chicken which is
tricky of course but
most likely not really so challenging
for white and also um the urban counter
gambit on which basically yeah maybe
it's not 100% sound but okay you need to
you need to have a quick look at least
to to not be completely confused of it
actually it's played against you to
spread relevant okay um let's um let's
start with um c6 which is the Slav very
popular opening of course so you get it
very often I think it's one of the most
common defenses against you form um okay
now at this point white basically has to
decide if you play at c3 or 9 f3 first
and only other option would be the
exchange variation which the CD file but
this doesn't really fit within the
aggressive ideas of the repertoire so um
let's go I'll actually suggest both
moves in some way but let's go with
Knight c3 first and then blacks main
move as so 96 let's play turn really
most of the times on other options are
mainly e6 which is the position you
mostly get with black playing ecigs
first and then c6 but still it can can
occur and also black could could take on
c4 which isn't played often but you
always need to check what actually
happens if black reps are born so this
is possible that may move as Schneider
6th SF a quick look for e6 I would
recommend player form the most
aggressive way to to combat this but
I'll have
little bit closer look at this yae 6
second e6 so this will be looked at
later on a DC form and why just play C
form on black defense the pawn otherwise
the sum is simply not a good idea to
take on c4 and give up the center yeah y
term tries to break up this pawns B form
Knight a to now c4 and before are both
hanging the black uses some the knight
development to UM to win a little bit of
time for for developing and getting the
pawn forward 95m Bishop c4 let's just
stop at this point of course um this can
be continued further on and this is so
maybe it's slightly better position for
white and the main point here is in the
center but it's got some nice some
advantage in the center with the two
advanced pawns and also there are some
weaknesses for black and c4 and c5
White Knight which is off side will come
back wire c1 and III later and this is a
position which is so very much playable
for white actually this line with taking
on c4 and move three is the only real on
well let's say argument where this
playing Knight c3 first if you don't
mind him taking on c4 here you can play
Knight c3 first and actually I think you
should play Knight is reversed as it
gives you more options then Knight f6 is
the main move and with more options I
mean at this point um White has has a
really huge choice you can play either
93 and actually allow black to take on
c4 which is the mainline Slav or white
could actually play
three year and cover the porn
immediately on see form which is my
first appearance on a bit less
aggressive the NIDA three is actually is
true it it is a little bit less
aggressive at first glance on but it got
the advantage of somewhat reducing the
theory and eaten I need to switch off
this arrows I'm not sure I'd how to do
this now what I'll do for the next video
um okay um because after III um a black
is basically reduced to three moves he
can go for forty six which is some
regular Marin variation we'll have a
look at the Sun at this later and also
possible as g6 which is so quiet line
but usually it's a little bit better for
white but it's not possible to to really
get them a huge edge or something but
why does a little bit better in the
center always and also arms and also of
course III a6 is possible the a6 Slav um
we're white just turn should play in
against Knight f3 and then b5 and then C
five which is a pretty aggressive line
despite first appearance um white
White's idea actually is to play before
and a form and really put some pressure
on the b5 pawn one important idea
actually here is some at some point that
you can know sometimes sacrifice piece
on b5 to get two pawns rolling before
and c5 so it's not a huge issue that you
have played III and if black goes for
some some minor lines like a 600 G or g6
um the the Marin variation here with
six okay wise goes nada three black
dolls 9b d7
and the Marin um of course an important
line because it's um played some really
often I'm here why it has some basically
two two ways to go forward you can play
Bishop d3 which is the old main line or
Quincy Quincy to Bishop d6 main move and
of course it's an aggressive repertoire
so I recommend to to study the move
seven G form which is of course very
aggressive um it's it's not a real pawn
sacrifice like an like can take on G
form but then white has got root G 1 and
okay there are some tricky lines with
Queen f6 but just to illustrate the main
point black returns then you get g7 back
and Jafar is very sharp line if black
doesn't know on real good answer is very
likely to be blown off the board so he
cannot simply Castle or play some other
slow move he needs to really react in a
specific fashion this a bit this line is
a bit out of fashion on the top level
but I guess it's still playable and
against I guess regular opposition are
still very dangerous um so it's it's
useful to study it and it's not not easy
to recommend a specific players played
this off because some basically all
world-class players have played it at
some point if you look at the database I
guess you find hundreds of games with
this g4 um let's return briefly to to
this position white of course also can
play Knight f3 which as I already
mentioned allows like to take here one
point of neither three here after
six like play c6 you're not committed to
e3 of course so here you actually have
the option to play different setups you
can just play u3 and return to the line
ayah I just showed but here also of
course have the possibilities to the
play Bishop g5 which is really a huge
body of theory but it's the sharpest
option and if you would like to study
deep and complicated lines you can go
for this on main main moves now for full
for black IDC form but Winnick variation
which is really ultra sharp this is the
main line but it goes on to move 20 or
something you really need to take a
little bit time to study this if you if
you're interested
I think objectively this is maybe just
good for whites but it's it is really
complicated but very sharp and
interesting stuff black can play h6 of
course um when White has the choice to
play quiet with taking on f6 or play
Bishop H form which in comparison I
would actually recommend it to play if
you allow the would Vinick and plays
this sharp line so it's just a just
consequent to to go for this and this is
some the main line maybe with h4 to come
this also has continued to move 20 nth
and further so it's it's very it's an
effort to study um but if you want to
play in an aggressive fashion you don't
have much choice here it's basically the
Bishop g4 Bishop g5 line allowing the
odd Vinnie again this h6 is in Moscow or
anti Moscow variation you don't have
much choice
um quiet lines just just don't just
don't do it here um either at this or
the g4 line I just just showed earlier
we beat stuff this that that's
interesting actually
maybe g3 it's an interesting try it's a
little bit of a mix of a Slav and a
Catalan opening why just ignore some on
that like and take the pawn for instance
oops a lot of errors this kind of
position can occur the black holds on to
the pawn with b5 but White has got
chances in the center with e4 and e5 um
this is interesting
let's it's played a lot my aggressive
players who don't want to really go into
the very very deep theory um playing an
idea three of course and allows DC form
which is the main lines laughs and there
you don't have much choice therefore is
the only move really to play and so the
old game midline d4 is just dubious um
so a form and then most most important
move them of course Bishop f5 and then I
just recommend 95f the most aggressive
option I'm interesting offbeat move here
is actually 9h form which is played
often but it's possible um so it's it's
all a trade off if you play Knight f3
here you actually are allowed so to say
to play those sharp lines but you need
to accept that black and can take on c4
if you go for for the e3 move order you
can save lots of theory of course
you